annual charity weekend is coming up on
Friday June 28th and Saturday June 29th
and the spot where they used to have the
area code underneath his eyes and his
eye black back in the day in San Diego
California Reggie Bush Iran the Rich
Eisen show to discuss this and so much
more good to see you sir you too thank
you so you're you're you're not what the
NFL Network any no info network a new
more all-in on Fox we have our new cost
football show we're starting yes Brady
Quinn Urban Meyer and Matt Leinart Rob
stone will be the host yes and I'll do
some stuff with on the pregame show as
well the Sunday pregame show as well
along with some Thursday night football
games so Thursday night you'll do so we
did with the NFL but now you'll be with
stray and New York yeah okay but you'll
still be on you know the NFL Network
there I mean it's simulcast and then
we're gonna be competitors on Sunday
morning like are we well you know I do
with the Sunday morning college football
base now no but you're doing the suck
you just said you're doing Sunday we go
do some Sunday not sitting on the I'm
not sitting on the under in the big
seats well you're on you're on against
me
Reggie I'll tell you what I never
against you know I never look I
I'll tell you what I told Ray Lewis
mmm-hmm and I said this to his face when
he took the job with the SPN to do their
Sunday show I come out of the smoke 9
a.m. Eastern Time every Sunday on the
NFL Network and then when I'm off the
air at 1:00 Eastern Time we're doing
Saturday um getting ready watch my
Michigan Wolverines so you'll be
watching me tonight looks like we have
we have the big now we have the big 12
and we have the pac-12 right so off off
we go and we'll have the Michigan Ohio
State game that's every year a game so
now let's get into this year Reggie yep
so Urban Meyer's on the second with you
mm-hmm
is it true that you and Matt are
whispering in his ear to know to go to
USC it's um no listen to an urban urban
says he's retired says
we did joke about it obviously how can
you not joke about it but we never
recruited him hard or anything like that
you know it's it's funny like a we're
going to now establish this relationship
right with Urban Meyer and I got a
chance to golf with him right and he's
and you can just tell he's been so
ingrained in coaching that like that's
the bubble he's been living in right and
so even on a golf course he's like
coaching me on the golf course over
there playing around the golf and in my
driver so I was hitting my drives and
they were getting a little high I was
still crushing them but he was like man
if you get that drive you get that
flight down you can be sending that
thing like three times I was like oh
thanks coach appreciate it
and so you know he's just he's so
engrained in coaching and even with like
we're questioning him about like pop
culture and social media he's got no
idea no idea he has zero idea what's
what's the worst pop culture rock that
he's pulled that you would think he
would know about and he asked me about
an actress I can't even remember her
name on bewitched okay I forget her name
and so we're who Elizabeth Montgomery
yes and he's like from the 60s he's like
you don't know who Elizabeth Montgomery
is are like coach I was born in 85 I
know and so we were playing golf and we
were playing at bel-air Country Club and
you know the guy with our host was kind
of showing us who used to live here who
used to live here and so he got all
excited about you know some of these
older yesin actresses right we're like
well coach do you know about you know do
you know who little yadi is or do you
know who and to my surprise he was like
no I'm a little Wayne guy I'm a snoop
dog guy okay and I was like okay all
right that's a start that's a start like
those are the biggest but what about
like these guys he had no idea yeah I
think like katharine hepburn used to
live on bel-air or something like that
probably her too he smoked a ball yeah
he starts waxing rhapsodic about on
Golden Pond yeah
so it was just funny but I think is
gonna play well on TV because you know
we're the younger guys and you got you
know one of the older guys sure just
kind of been out of touch from the
social media world or stuff so I think
it's gonna be fun well I mean when I
heard about this about the rumor that
you and Leinart were like German in his
ear not gonna us see it didn't pass the
smell test because clearly if you want
to build a television show right you
need to keep Urban Meyer in that seat
for a while you don't want him anywhere
else other than that seat yeah but be me
being the Michigan Wolverine and the
Rose Bowl they're happy he's going the
Rose Bowl hold on a second I'm not doing
it the Rose Bowl the Rose Bowl that I
covered was Beau's last year his last
game never losing to USC and junior
salehoo I've never seen anybody I
thought there were 250 fives in the
field ending and obviously the Michigan
Ohio State rivalry there has been
somewhat one-sided recent days to hear
that it's possible that Urban's thinking
of coming back to coach just right after
leaving Ohio State is a hornet's nest
that I can't but try and kick a little
bit here listen but there's no there
there is that what you're saying
i flat-out asked him and it was in a
joking way but I was like coach what if
somebody offers you 100 million would
you come back he said nope I'm done I
was like you sure cuz I yeah I'm done I
was like because I know a guy he was
just like straight face nope I'm done I
was like alright this is gonna be a lot
of fun this year Reggie Bush here on the
Richardson show let's talk a little bit
of NFL's well what do you think of the
drafting of Kyler murray any issues you
think here obviously you played with
Drew Brees and who is sort of the
Godfather of this so-called vertically
challenged quarterback so what do you
think here I'm excited for him because I
feel like more and more quarterbacks
coming out of college football look like
Russell Wilson they look like kala Merri
and they play like those guys right and
so you know a lot of people are still in
love with the Tom Brady's and
and the drew brees and but even Anna
Rogers is a scrambler right you know who
we consider to have one of the best arms
in the NFL and so I think listen this
kid has tremendous upside is he short
yes but does that mean he can't play
football no because when I turn on the
highlights when I look when I watch and
play football he has an arm he can throw
it he's accurate he can create space
with his legs which is you know in the
NFL it's it's it's tough it's tough to
you know taking all those things and so
I'm excited for him I think is gonna be
a challenge for him these first couple
years what do you thinks gonna be
childish don't think he has great talent
around him and then you have a
first-time head coach who's trying to
figure out the NFL he got a rookie
quarterback who's gonna be trying to
figure out so there's gonna be a lot of
figuring it out in this first year which
you're in division with the Los Angeles
Rams Seattle Seahawks who are always
tough right they're just you start with
those two teams right there mm-hmm and
you got to win your division like that
that's a tough that's a tough ask you
know I even listen I reached out to Fitz
you know I've talked to Fitz you know a
lot and we and we we joke around I was
like Fitz you sure you want to keep
playing like because you know it could
be tough you know for you guys this year
and so he obviously fits the competitor
he is he's like man I just love the
process I'm in love with the process so
I think Colin Murray has tremendous
upside I'm excited for him but I do
think this year is gonna be very tough
for well I mean if you the only
comparisons you can make right now do
you want to talk about guys who move
around and can wing it yeah coming out
of college last couple years you got
mahomes was obviously an outlier made 50
touchdowns insane yeah there's a reason
why we've never seen a guy in his first
full years two years out of college the
exact touch not yeah
then there's deshaun Watson mm-hmm okay
I mean now obviously Watson is taller in
stature yeah but I remember the first
Thursday night game that he made his
first start okay Cincinnati ran went in
from the 50-yard line
when he had so many offensive linemen
down and tied ends down that you didn't
know who was blocking or was catching oh
it was insane short week you had to come
out of nowhere and
play and huh and then he had that
remarkable run that got cut short by a
knee injury unfortunately yeah
why can't Kyler Murray do that he can't
do that and you know I think listen do
they always talk about rent quarterbacks
who run the biggest issue is that they
run and you expose yourself to getting
hit or to injuries
the thing I love about Russell Wilson he
gets down right he takes off and runs
but he gets down he you don't see
Russell us and trying to run through
people or he lives to fight another day
because as long as Russell Wilson is
healthy that team is gonna be in a good
spot right and you just that's the thing
you that running quarterbacks have to
understand even Aaron Rodgers has dealt
with this right is when you take off and
run you got to get down you cannot be
out there trying to be Cam Newton
running people over because even Cam
Newton is now is having shoulder
injuries that are catching up to him I
mean look at when obviously you know
leaps for the endzone against the Rams
the Rams and his his knee go is
Garoppolo should have gotten out of
bounds last year instead he took a hit
right on the sideline and we're still
waiting to see what he looks like as a
every week in week out quarterback
Reggie Bush here in the Rich Eisen show
levy on bail in the case offense yeah I
mean I'm trying to make heads or tails
of what this is gonna look like
so if the report that they've now
seemingly swept under the rug yeah that
he didn't the coach think that bill
deserved the money that he got yeah how
do you think this is gonna work out this
fall Reggie Bush get your popcorn ready
I think it's gonna be interesting
because for a lot of different reason I
said it's not any fun Network you know
you can go back to the film you know
when a months ago you know when I'm
still there doing Total Access I said
this is gonna be a very interesting year
for the New York Jets before a lot of
different reasons one that you know
there were reports coming out that Adam
GaSe didn't want to hire Greg Williams
son you know and then we have this
coming out and then you have Greg
Williams
you know the defense coordinator who's
also Joe Vitt the linebackers coach were
together in New Orleans during the whole
pounding gate think together you know I
mean there was a bunch of issues with
that and so I just this is gonna be an
interesting year and it's already
playing out right we're already seeing
you know the GM got fired already
and it's just like no what we're just
doing you know his last couple years it
just feels like there hasn't been a lot
of direction from that organization and
so I was happy for a lady on Bill when
he got another opportunity to play
because I was a little worried you know
because yes he is a great player but
people aren't paying running backs like
that anymore you know and he is a rare
specimen I do believe that and I do
believe when he's healthy when he's he's
one of the best you know is him and Zeke
and todd gurley
you know those are the those are the
cream of the crop and so now he's going
to a team where that's not being
Roethlisberger throwing that football
you know you got a second-year
quarterback who shows some struggles you
know we're turning the football over you
know he's gonna have to be the leader in
that room he's gonna have to be one of
the older guys gonna me have to be the
veteran much different than where he
came from you know with the Pittsburgh
Steelers where you know Big Ben was was
you know the leader and you have a coach
Tomlin who had been there you know for a
long time who was vested into the
organization you got a first time you
got a you know a new head coach who
already showed struggles in that
division and you just it just seems like
a lot of baggage right yeah does it sure
does can you thrown it all together and
you've got an owner of a team who
basically admitted you know having a
coach and a general manager search is
not what he thought he could wrap his
arms around and his brother is the
ambassador of the UK may or may not
still be there and a year from now and
then he comes back I mean it's there's
there's a lot going on and on top of all
of that you got to beat the Patriots I
know and and and and I believe they
they're gonna win it again next year
seems that way because Bray unless Brady
out of the blue Reggie this I'm already
thinking about what am I gonna say you
know for my prediction this year
and unless out of the blue somehow
someway thought I'm affects his play in
such a negative way that one of these
teams in the AFC can catch them and
surpass them or win in Foxborough in
January yeah I don't see how they lose
again I don't see how they lose again
either I mean this is an I mean that's
even with Gronk on I mean cuz you know
Ben Watson he's gonna come back at some
point and I think that he'll be he'll be
more than serviceable yeah
it feels like that division has been
like the path of least resistance for a
long time you know and even when like
what
maybe when Rex was there you know that's
when it was it was more competitive
right but since Rex has left at that
team it just seems like that's been the
path of least resistance for the
Patriots you know that division like
they've they've easily won that division
at some point you know they're gonna
face Kansas City or we'll see what the
Steelers look like you never know what
the Colts might be able to do at a
Cleveland Browns looking really strong
on paper I know that but you think when
when rubber meets Road that they are
gonna be a team Baker Mayfield commit
like first week of second week of
January
I like Baker a lot me too I was at the
game where he took over we had the
Thursday night game I loved what I saw I
love his energy I think this is the
youthfulness that Odell needs right from
the quarterback position and from the
team standpoint interesting you know
listen I think just the the the matching
of personalities with Eli and Odell just
wasn't working out you know what I mean
and he just brought something different
to the game that Eli couldn't he
couldn't match that energy I think Baker
can and I think this is going to be a
place where he can kind of spread his
wings I took when I when I saw Odell I
ran into him and we text every now and
then I said you have an opportunity to
kind of do what we did in New Orleans so
you have an opportunity to be and to
really take our franchise from nothing
to now to being a respected franchise
and organization because for the longest
Cleveland has not been respected when I
got to New Orleans
they were the aints
right people will go to the games with
trash bags on your head not saying it
was just me but we had an opportunity to
change that and now when you think about
the Saints you don't think about the
ancient north course you think about you
know a real contender and I think O'Dell
and that team with those young pieces
they have an ability to to to do that
same thing can you stick around okay I
want to take a break come back because
there is one more running back situation
I want to hit and then obviously talk
about your annual charity again Reggie
Bush is here on the Rich Eisen show
don't you dare move and by the way
Timothy Olyphant making his way to our
studio we'll talk Deadwood movie and
more with him when we have a third hour
but when we come back more Reggie Bush
one more segment with Reggie Bush who
you can follow on Twitter and Instagram
as I do both at Reggie Bush
I appreciate the follow of course Reggie
come on now your your interesting to
follow that I'm sure so what is
happening with Todd Gurley here in Los
Angeles you were obviously somebody who
knows how to run a ball and also be a
multiple thread out of the backfield at
a high level for a championship caliber
team and also know what it's like to
fight through injury yes we had Sean
McVeigh in that chair what was it about
a month ago right Chris I try Mike give
or take yeah did he said it he wasn't
hurt last year I mean he wasn't hurt he
might have been injured he didn't say
anything but he didn't say like that his
knee was hurt to the point where he
wasn't functional as he was for the
first 15 weeks of the season this was
six weeks ago was was final yeah what
are your what and he also said yesterday
even though he's not doing anything at
the OTAs he's under a great plan
it's what Sean McVeigh said yeah you
look at this and think what well I think
there's definitely obviously something
there I've heard reports about arthritis
and you know listen every football
player has arthritis I don't care what
position you play everybody has
arthritis even coaches got arthritis so
to me that's a non-issue because
everybody has to play through that
everybody deals with that I had
microfracture surgery after my third
year and writers were saying oh he
probably has another two three years
left I end up playing another seven
years in a plane 11 year so to me it's
all about Tiger le's pain tolerance you
know what he can take and I think one of
the best things they did last year was
finding CJ Anderson because they found a
complement to him and I think maybe that
could be the plan going forward because
ultimately you want to have targer Lee
healthy in the postseason
right like during the regular season
okay you want to win games I get that
they got a great offer they got good
weapons so they can still win games
without having to feed him 25 30 times a
game right you can still get a lot of
production out of Tiger Lee maybe 15
times a game you know touching the
football and that's running the football
catching up
was kind of like that was my plan when
was in New Orleans right and so I think
he'll be fine
it's just a matter of his pain tolerance
what he can what he can take but he has
had a lot of carries is it is it
possible that what you're describing can
happen and such an intense way that one
game it would affect you another game it
might not because it's not as intense
yeah would that be the wave to see and
explain how he could dominate Dallas as
he did in the divisional game and then
in the NFC champion in the Super Bowl be
a non-factor yeah I think so
and I think maybe just kind of flared up
on him whatever it was happening with
his knee you know he got a lot of
touches in that game he probably got
banged up
you know I when I playing with Calvin
I'm in Detroit Calvin was banged up all
the time Calvin Johnson yeah he was
banged up and so there he would have to
miss practice all week you know but
still
imagine that missing practice all week
for most of the season and still going
out and putting up those kinds of
numbers you know and I see and I think
that that could be a great plan for
targer Lee you know keeping him on a
pitch count during the week of practice
because ultimately he knows how to run a
football he knows how to run inside his
own he knows how to run a screen and and
so really it's just how do we keep him
as fresh as possible you know throughout
the season and so that we do have him in
a postseason because they're gonna be
right back into postseason again you
know they got they got the weapons they
got the team so I got a good coach are
you concerned about Gurley like what am
i gay but would be your level of concern
here I want to scale a 1 to 10 I'd say
maybe 5 you know maybe a 5 just because
I would be concerned as to you know what
the plan is from the doctors and from
the team you know physicians just you
know what are they doing to keep him
healthy you know how are they making
sure that he's always at his best on
Sundays because that's where you need
him you don't need him getting banged up
for training camp preseason games you
know so for me after I had my
microfracture surgery I never really
played in a preseason game you know
maybe one you know one a year for a
handful of
and that was it wouldwould arthritis b
makes sense with the fact that they're
being so secretive as well I mean that's
because known is a really super mountain
so secretive a we were we've been having
a little bit of fun even though
obviously it's not a laughing matter
yeah but just like what will we find out
first why Malcolm Butler didn't play for
the Patriots in that loss that is or why
Marshawn Lynch didn't get to the
football on the one-yard line or why
Todd Gurley in the Super Bowl would just
be standing booth yeah I mean clearly
listen if he's healthy you know he's
gonna play right right and so obviously
he was not healthy so you can't negate
that fact right you can't dispute that
and so obviously there was something
that was fired up whether it was I heard
it was a bone bruise now I have had to
play with bone bruises before that is
painful and there's nothing you can do
to speed up healing a bone bruise you
can use all the ice in stem hyper
fairness and all this you know oxygen
training it does not matter a bone
bruise was gonna heal over time when
it's ready there's nothing you can do to
speed it up in the couple minutes I have
left with you Reggie Bush Reggie Bush
org for information on being part of
your annual charity weekend in San Diego
on the frauds last Friday and Saturday
of this month what's what should folks
know about all this folks you know
that's so we support a foundation called
the birthday party project and what they
do is they go to homeless shelters all
throughout the US and they throw
birthday parties for homeless kids and
when you think about that concept is
very simple but the idea behind it is
that kids growing up their fondest
memories are birthdays Christmas
Halloween maybe Thanksgiving most of
these kids don't get a chance to
experience that and so when I've been
able to go to some of these birthday
parties that they throw they rent out
big halls and they get food donated toys
donated they got DJs music they're
bringing a team of people they've got
games and you see these kids faces light
up it's over a birthday cake right
because even like birthday candles are
still like even though adults is still
like wow you know like birthday candles
and sure you know still kind of a cool
thing and most of these kids have never
gotten that and so putting joy on a
kid's face by doing something simple
like
that to me is some I want to be a part
of and I love you know just what they're
doing
and they are the beneficiaries of our of
our Bush family celebrity weekend okay
we got a golf tournament we got a 5k run
we have a foundation dinner which my boy
Alex Thomas hosts know we bring
comedians in who do stand-up comedy at
the end of the the foundation dinner
it's just a lot of fun black-tie dinner
liked our dinner yes sir good dad
yeah she's very rich well I mean you
know Reggie not busy I appreciate that
thorough it'll throw out invitation
towards the end of this conversation you
know because it says star-studded
weekend yeah you're a star and I
appreciate that I think I put the stud
in studded you don't mind me saying I
think so damn hard I think you did
appreciate it dad
I appreciate the invitation I think I'll
be out of town unfortunately okay is
that what they call it convenient being
out of town wants to be seen with Mike
now that he's that he's tied Mike in the
Callaway challenge for the four points
at the end you could have gone for the
easy two I'm a I'm a I'm all-in kind of
guy you know I mean blackjack 21 I got
I'm all-in you got to push it all this
good luck and on your charity event
obviously and let's let's keep having
you back here since you're locally here
I'll have you any time yeah you and Matt
Leinart rob stone and also Urban Meyer
Urban Meyer I don't know why that name
just escaped me Brady Quinn Brady Quinn
I definitely want to see a push oh yeah
we will have someone coming on the
deadwood movie and more in the news
update hour three four more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app